first thing i hear is hey this is stan
lee i know who this
is i know that voice anywhere man i
watched every episode of spiderman's
amazing friends
but a huge fan for years man i know all
your work so glad jim put us in touch
with one another
let's talk about your movie very
flattered that you want me to be in it
he's going but i have a bit of an issue
before i could say yes i was like all
right he goes in your movie you have a
scene
where i'm talking about the girl that
got away he's very touching scene
really wonderful he's going however if i
play myself in a movie and talk about
the girl that got away the girl i got at
home
will lock me out of the house so what
are we gonna do about this i can't hurt
joni's feelings like
joanie's only always been the only one
so i can't go into a movie and say that
like
i there was some other girl before joni
got a suggestion
okay he goes what if there's another
scene
where like i tell his friend that i was
only kidding and that way everybody
knows
that i you know i could tell the story
but i didn't have some other girl that
got away before i met jonny
and i was like i will do whatever you
want i could totally
absolutely do that is adorable i look at
you thinking about your wife's feelings
in this dopey ass movie
i was like of course i could do that and
i always thought it was incredibly sweet
and that he was such a loving husband
and then i got to know stan over the
years and i was right it was very sweet
and he was a very loving husband
you want to be loved as much in this
life as stan lee loved his wife joan
but stan lee also one of the most
strategic people i've ever met
in my life no dumb man very smart cookie
and what he did in asking for another
scene
to explain himself to some other
character
was he got another scene in the movie
simply by being like shouldn't there be
another scene where i explained that i'm
kidding i'm like well of course of
course there'll be another scene
stan hi hey hey you know i think he
bought it
yeah yeah what kind of story did you
give him oh it was the vulture soliloquy
you know from the spider-man anniversary
issue
love be a vulture tonight yeah well i
can't thank you enough
oh forget it but you know i think you
ought to get him some help
he seems to be really hung up on
superhero sex organs
but he'll outgrow it okay oh mr lee
yeah excelsior oh you got that right see
ya